Mitt Romney was asked now that George
Anthony devolder Santos has been charged
criminally with multiple charges what
should happen
and I love that Mitt Romney doesn't just
say he should resign he says he should
already have resigned and this is
exactly the right answer I actually wish
that there were more Republicans
some of them are going to come around
now and say well he should now resign I
wish more people said what Mitt Romney
says in this short six second clip to
CNN's Manu Raju
he should have resigned a long time ago
he said embarrassment to our party he's
embarrassment to the United States
Congress Okay so
yes he should resign now and actually
Republicans in the house should hold a
vote and they should kick him out but
the right take as Mitt Romney has been
one of the few Republican voices willing
to say this is that he should have been
gone a long time ago he never should
have gotten to this point in time
even in even prior to the actual
indictments these Republicans seem very
scared to just come out and say it or
they don't believe it but good for Mitt
Romney for making that clear